today's topic men are trash it's a
saying that I've seen quite a lot and so
recently it was discussed on a podcast
called the grapevine we're gonna watch
the video and react until that behavior
is unlearned you're going to be trash to
me every time like there have been
instances where a story of a woman is
raped comes out here goes a black man
started defending your sister well I
just think she should give out your
numbers be more pleasant is she telling
the truth you don't know what I'm going
through that day somebody and you just
see me you should smile for baby you
okay
but you're telling you to smile because
it makes you feel better from you and
you're right man do say that I've seen
it happen that man say that you should
smile more that's annoying as hell but
guess what women say to me I should
smile be no you know just like cuz
they're scared of you yeah yeah I'm a
bit scary but no they do say that to me
as well did they say that
you should smile more you should they
have such a beautiful smile should smile
more often that's man anyway and I am
NOT denying what you're going through
because I've seen it happen actually
just pretty much all lives mattered her
just saying I'm just saying that women
are trash too we're trash we're human
beings
I was really ready to sail wasn't [ __ ]
but you honestly captured entirely what
I was going to say as far yet except
accountable and I really think that I
don't - man Santa y'all a [ __ ] because
y'all really aren't [ __ ] but like it's
just really telling y'all how hold
yourselves accountable so why don't you
say men I try to hold yourselves
accountable instead of men or trash cuz
if you tell me man you need to hold
yourself accountable for the action that
you do yeah if I do something bad
women OHS excuse me no what I meant to
say is that when we need to make better
choices I don't know why you saying this
other line when you could say all right
nobody is free from no [ __ ]
like everybody because power leads
towards men the way that men act has an
effect on our society and if we cannot
hold men accountable
let me go talk about we try to distract
my saying that woman ain't [ __ ] you
don't fix anything all you do is
distract away from the from the
situation of how you behave in how you
backw because you know that if you have
to give that up that movies you gonna
have a power that you think you deserve
comment on the response of all right
listen to us I think we can all
acknowledge that misogyny is a problem
you can all acknowledge that we women
have suffered in a lot of different ways
and I think we all ideally want to come
to solutions that best work for everyone
mm-hm and I can also recognize that you
know it's a problem that's persisted for
a long time mm-hm it's been an extreme
problem mmm maybe your solution was also
very extreme with men are trash and you
know if you say this to women don't be
like well listen we're not talking about
all men talking about men who are trash
Sophia doesn't hit her - it's doesn't
identify you you shouldn't be insulted
that don't say man if you came out and
said Ethiopians are garbage people and
then I was like I am offended by that
and you'd be like whoa I'm not saying
you're a garbage person just Ethiopians
who are garbage people well you see
opions regard you know I don't think
people always quite understand the
importance of the words that they choose
to use to define whatever term they want
you know like there's a reason why when
it comes to opening up a business
any marketing firm like what big
companies will pave marketing firms
millions of dollars to find the right
slogan to find the right words for their
ads why because they understand how that
stuff is programmed in our brains and
what emotions it evokes and so you can
come here and say that men are trash has
this meaning or that meaning and that's
great for you but we are as a society
already have real understandings of what
the word trash means and I just think
that it's so toxic for people to refer
to other human beings as discardable
items as the worst waste humanly
possible and so when you refer to people
as that like trash is not redeemable you
know you say like mint unlearn your
misogyny and you won't be trash to me
like trash is not redeemable trash does
not get second chances you want to
become trash you are discarded to be
destroyed forever and the fact that we
refer to other human beings that way
blows my mind blows my mind we're not
being hyperbolic either we're actually
just saying no you are trash you are b2b
I'm just like okay if you want to cast
those aspersions on everybody else feel
free I just think it's not the smartest
way to engage in this conversation and
it really sets people off on the wrong
path you know if I was to look at what's
happening in Chicago and I'm like well
that's evil blackness the term evil
blackness even though it may actually
properly represent to some degree what's
happening over there it's still a bad
term to use because blackness isn't
inherently evil the same way masculinity
isn't inherently toxic right but if you
you frame it that way of course people
are gonna program in there would brain
that way because it's it's not good
marketing and so I would just tell
people to you know like one of the girls
earlier said you know men are trash just
means like men hold yourself accountable
then just say man hold yourselves
accountable and people won't have an
issue with it I can't have an issue with
that I mean you have to hold yourself
accountable no matter who you are what
you do on a percent who do something bad
you do some doodoo you got to pick it up
right so I don't know why people engage
in this kind of language I think for me
just seems like people use these terms
because it simplifies whatever the
problem is but these problems are
complex they're new ones they're not
easy to define and so when you use these
big terms and you use it with such
polarizing words of course it's gonna
set people off so I don't know why
people who say this thing or like why
men are surprises
who wouldn't be you know if I look to
the fact that you know you know black
people predominantly have lower IQ
scores and I said well dumb blackness
and you like oh my god I can't believe
I'm like no I'm just referring to the
people who are actually dumb you would
still take it the wrong way because of
the top I don't know to me it's just
basic this is super simple but
apparently what I'm saying is
counterproductive and it's reinforcing
the idea that men are trash and it's
silencing the lived experience of women
hold other men accountable like listen I
don't know anybody around me that
catcalls no if I find out if a guy was
doing that I check real quick right I
don't know anybody around me that that's
it if I knew a guy who's doing some some
Weinstein stuff he wouldn't be my friend
you we wouldn't associate if someone if
one of my friend Weinstein's my Epstein
that's pretty good you know so I'm like
I don't know to me the language I get
what you guys are trying to get at I
just think sometimes the words that and
especially sing that in public you know
like having black women say that about
black men in public
I don't couldn't do a lot of stuff that
black men saved by black men but you
guys saying this either like to me seems
counterproductive because then other
people are seeing this and other
commuters seen that I'm like oh is that
how they talk about each other the women
say men are trash and [ __ ] are saying
like [ __ ] Inc it's not good it's not
it's not good for a psyche you know I
remember as a kid like the first time
like someone you'd let me like a giant
insult at me right Ryan they said yo you
had a monkey ears that [ __ ] stayed with
me forever
imagine being a young kid hearing your
mom say like y'all all men are trash
like that's the person that's raising
you that stays that stays with you
forever so one day I was I was working
my girl was playing was playing it and
my girl my sister was playing and I said
to my sister I said a bad word I said I
thought I called it stupid or something
like that and repeated call it my mom no
my dad stopped it's like yo don't do
that now that you're just plain even if
you're just playing yeah there's there's
an impact and that's your sister
yeah so there's other games you can play
than calling yourself stupid that's all
so listen that's all we're gonna say for
today we want to hear your thoughts what
do you guys think leave your comments
below peace y'all
it's Friday you don't forget to take out
the man I mean the trash so why are you
putting this on us I think it's
problematic because what it does is it
diminishes and it silences the lived
experiences of women of oppression
towards women and no it doesn't make
sense to say we're all trash because
women cannot systematically oppressed
men so actually no women are not trash
and I don't fully understand why men
continue to take the men are trash
sentiment so personally because you
literally compared me to trash no no no
if you talk about this system talk about
this system but you can't say I don't
understand why man the way why do you
think if so personally we're talking
about a system then talk about the
system then because all this time what
you're saying is not talking about the
system and saying man are trash like
there's no really three ways with you
understand what I'm saying it's pretty
direct man are trash it's pretty direct
I don't hear system in there I don't
hear none of that so if you want to talk
about a system talk about the system
that's fine I and I'm for that
and yes there are problems within that
system that meant mplet but implemented
themself way and they're living and
they're going through fine I get that
and you're right
yes you guessed it you was right but
what you say is not that and what you
say is man are trash so when I think
about that and I read the sentence I see
man what they are and trash all right
all right sorry about that
[Music]